trapped between the woods and a highway
in belarus
these people have been walking towards
the polish border anxious to enter the
european union
on the other side
polish security forces in riot gear part
of the 12 000 that have been stationed
there guarding the frontier
preventing hundreds of refugees and
migrants from breaching the border
but it is a deadlock that risks igniting
into another migration crisis on the
doorstep of the eu for months thousands
have been entering the block through
belarus at first via lithuania and
latvia now mainly through poland the eu
has accused belarusian leader alexander
lukashenko of orchestrating wave upon
wave of undocumented migrants and asylum
seekers in retaliation they say for
sanctions it imposed on his government
over its violent crackdowns on the
opposition
caught in the middle of this
brinkmanship those attempting to escape
the harsh conditions they find
themselves in with no shelter
being steered towards poland by
belarusian state border officials
some had taken the chance after hearing
that belarusian travel agents were
selling visa invitations to the eu
only to find themselves surviving for
weeks in the forest that border poland
and belarus
they give us the cutters they
they provide everything then but when
you say when you said to them okay i
want to go to mansec i want to go
i want to go back to my country it's so
dangerous they said no you should go to
boland bill belarus they bought the gun
to our to our heads
when we were when
when we said we need to go to mensa so
far poland's nationalist government has
refused help from the eu's frontier
agency despite reports by polish border
guards of hostile behaviour and threats
from belarusian forces and for those
stuck in this no man's land there is no
guarantee how long they will have to
face the elements with little access to
food and water
human pawns between two hostile
neighbors sonia gallego al jazeera